This next story is absolutely insane.
It's dystopian.
It's it's really straight out of A Handmaid's
Tale, much like some of the people Donald
Trump is considering for the Supreme Court
to replace Ruth Bader Ginsburg.
Although we'll get to them on tomorrow's show.
But it is now alleged that the United States
in 2020, under Donald Trump is performing
forced sterilization.
Unwanted hysterectomy is on women detained
by Donald Trump's ICE, Immigrations and Customs
Enforcement.
Forced sterilization is what we are talking
about here.
PRISM has learned, according to a source familiar
with the situation, that gynecologist Mahendra
Amien, based in Georgia, has been performing
forced sterilizations as per prism.
The organizations project South.
The Georgia Detention Watch.
Georgia Latino Alliance for Human Rights and
Georgia, a south Georgia immigrant support
network, have filed a complaint on behalf
of immigrants detained by the United States
detained inside of ICE CDC, which is operated
by private prison company LaSalle Corrections.
And the organization alleges that five women
could be more.
But this specific complaint refers to five
women sterilized at the facility between October
and December of last year.
Don Wooten, a licensed practical nurse employed
by ICE CDC, is the whistleblower.
And she says, I've had several inmates tell
me that they've been to see the doctor and
they've had hysterectomies is and they don't
know why they went or why they're going.
A spokesperson for the Southern Poverty Law
Center, which has represented people detained
there, confirmed to prison that Dr. Amien
saw multiple women represented by the organization.
The spokesperson couldn't currently confirm
the extent of the appointments.
And according to the whistleblower in the
project?
S complaint, Amien recently took out the wrong
ovary on a detained woman.
The women do not appear to be consenting to
getting hysterectomies.
They are not receiving translation services.
Many times there are language barriers when
they are getting complicated medical information
conveyed to them, they have no translator.
Sometimes nurses are reportedly communicating
using Google Voice on their phones to translate
Google Translate on their phones, rather,
or by asking other detainees to translate.
That's not how we do things.
Or I thought we weren't doing things that
way in the United States.
And one woman was given three different explanations
about what is being done to her medically.
This is some of the ugliest stuff that we've
heard of there.
If you go back and look at U.S. history, there
is an ugly history of reproductive injustice
in the United States.
The Tuskegee experiment used African-American
sharecroppers to test and understand syphilis.
With researchers refusing to tell patients
that they have syphilis or to treat them in
order to see what happens with untreated syphilis.
Men were denied treatment and many died or
went blind or insane.
The American doctors behind the birth control
pill first tested the birth control pill on
low income Puerto Rican women.
There have been nationwide eugenics campaigns
targeting wide swaths of people for sterilization
because they were considered undesirable.
So there is a history of this and it's happening
now and it gets even worse.
The doctor, Dr Mahendra Amien, appears not
to even be a board certified OPG y and they
are a gynecologist.
But a spokesperson for the American Board
of Obstetrics and Gynecology said to The Daily
Beast that according to their records, Dr
Mahendra Amin is not even certified.
Now, it's sort of like the icing on the cake,
right?
Shocker that the Trump administration's choice
of doctor for forced sterilizations is not
board certified.
But it's just another detail in the insanity.
ICE is not commenting about the certification
of Dr. Amien.
And we have we are in the process of trying
to figure out what the hell is going on here.
The obvious question is, is Doctor Amien going
to be prosecuted?
Probably not.
Is he going to be made surgeon general?
Seems like as reasonable of a question given
the insanity of this administration.
This really is this is concentration camp
stuff.
If it's even a fraction of what's being alleged.
It is the worst of the worst.
And we really need to remind ourselves as
a country that we have committed atrocities.
In the past and we've made improvements, but
things are still going on.
We can't put our guard down for a moment.
The vigilance must stay.
And when you let lunatics in power, bad things
happen.
It's not just elections have consequences.
It's also not paying attention, even for a
moment, has major consequences.
Human rights abuses.
It it it's it's dystopian.
I'm almost at a loss for words.
And unfortunately, we are repeating some of
the worst things from American history.
Right now, it's having an effect
on our reputation.
And that's
what
I want to talk about next.